it's great to be joined today by Sean
McFate who is a senior fellow at the
Atlantic Council which is a Washington
DC think tank also author of the new
novel deep black a Tom Locke novel Sean
you know in preparing for the interview
I was reading about your background
which includes military service it
includes mercenary work it includes work
in many parts of the world which we will
talk about how do you sort of get into
that line of work well in my case I kind
of fell backwards into it like most
people in that world I came from a
military background I spent eight years
as a paratrooper and the US Army's 82nd
Airborne Division and then I got out and
I went to the so-called dark side and in
my case they found me I didn't like seek
it out
so how does that work in other words is
there well well first I guess we should
talk about when you say they found you
what types of organizations are
generally included under this umbrella
of mercenaries well they would not call
themselves mercenaries they call
themselves contractors but in my case it
was a large multinational corporation
that does work for the US government as
part of many would call the
military-industrial complex the name of
the cup is called dying for
international they do like they're like
a four billion dollar company a year
they do many things from repairing
airplanes to cooking food to you name it
but they have this small little wing
that does things that the CIA would
normally do or special forces would
normally do and that's who contacted me
and when you say things the CIA or
Special Forces would do at the very
30,000 foot level why would that type of
work be contracted out to begin with in
other words why are these types of
organizations even in existence as
opposed to just doing these actions and
activities internally well most people
would be surprised by how much of our
foreign policy is outsourced in in some
ways you know like I say things like the
CIA or Special Forces what I was doing
and I was
mostly in Africa I was doing armed deals
I was doing taking care of warlords I
was building small armies for US
interest in one case even helped prevent
a genocide in rwanda and burundi region
these are things that traditionally the
CIA would have done the reason why it's
being outsourced now is for a few
reasons one is that when you really want
something done with a zero footprint
operation you don't go to the CIA you
don't go to the Pentagon you could but
you can also go to the pen you also go
to the private sector because they give
you great plausible deniability meaning
that if something goes wrong if the
mission of two politically risky you
don't want your SEAL team guys plated on
television as prisoners of war then you
hire contractors because you could say
well we don't know who really they were
it gives you a new layer of plausible
deniability which matters a great deal
in an Information Age does that
plausible deniability come at a cost in
the sense that an operation carried out
by a group like the one you worked for
would be sort of apples to apples more
expensive than the government handling
it internally well actually contractors
are cheaper than the government and they
can actually be better than the
government at what they do we always
think that contractors are not good at
what they do they over charge yeah they
do overcharge but they can actually be
very effective however you know I think
that the bigger point is when you when
you outsource to companies you don't
really also know what you're getting is
a lot of problems with us most people
will think that you're getting like X
guys like myself US Army guys you're not
I was working alongside with people from
you know Salvador Philippines Mexico in
some ways the globalization of force is
like the globalization of a t-shirt it
comes to cheaper if it's coming from a
sort of so-called developing nation and
so we have a we're creating
unintentionally the US has created this
sort of global market for private
military labor that's sloshing around
the world
right now so you've addressed and you
did a very interesting reddit AMA you've
been interviewed a number of times and
and also through the fictionalization of
your career in the Tom Locke novel
series you've addressed areas in which
there are many misconceptions when it
comes to this type of work when it comes
to concerns right at the same way that
the plausible deniability of using these
types of organizations is a good thing
for the government is it also possibly
or in practice providing cover for
really horrible things that are being
done I mean the risks of this are much
worse than people think
first of all about using contractors now
contractors do not count as boots on the
ground and they don't count as
casualties you know so that's why you
see in contractors rise for both
Republican and Democratic white houses
this is so much so that like the Iraq
war we had a 1 to 1 ratio for every
contractor there was a true that's you
know 50% troops or 2% contractors in
World War 2 is only 10% contractors and
when I talk to and recently as you may
or may not know that former founder of
Blackwater Erik Prince proposed a new
strategy for Afghanistan where we
replace all troops in Afghanistan with
mercenaries right you know which is
ridiculous we're getting to the point
now where contracting is becoming the
American Way of war and what this does
is it circumvents you know democratic
accountability Armed Forces because
contractors do not answer to anybody
except for who holds the contract and
more importantly is that others are now
imitating this model we have mercenaries
all over the world who use blue or
former Iraq and Afghanistan contractors
are now looking for the next paycheck
this is a very dangerous development so
we heard a little bit about the sort of
legal upside for the US government to
using these types of contractors what
about law within the countries that the
contractors operate I mean what what law
applies in those countries since they
don't count as boots on the ground I'm
guessing that
they are not operating within what you
would consider a theater of war or maybe
I'm wrong I don't know well we don't
know the answer so in you know there's
most of these company mercenaries armed
contractors go to conflict markets where
rule of law is already very weak these
are civil wars essentially so for
example in 2007 ten years ago a bunch of
Blackwater mercenaries contractors
killed 17 innocent Iraqis in a traffic
circle in Baghdad called nice or swear
this became one of the low points of the
Iraq war this problem it may have been
the the worst war crime you know done in
the Iraq war by US forces and I'm
including them as US forces there was a
US contract you know what what happened
to them after they murdered civilians
well they got an airplane they went home
that's all that happened to them they
were tried in Iraq they weren't really
they weren't tried in America until
years later and a very controversial
trial and this is the problems of future
if if we had a mercenary working under
the US government in Iraq from a place
like I'll just pick on Guatemala and
that soldiers counterinsurgency
techniques are different than ours and
he massacres and you know a whole family
in Afghanistan where's he go on trial is
it in America is it in Afghanistan is it
you know from his home country or is it
nowhere we still don't know so this is
the problem is that there are is no real
rule of law international laws really
don't apply very well and at the end of
the day who's going to arrest
mercenaries Mercer Hayes will just shoot
the law enforcement when it comes to
some of the other stereotypes that exist
about these types of contractors can you
address number one how the mortality
rate compares for contractors versus
official service members I'm guessing
the answer varies on where you're
talking about number two there's this
idea that the pay is just exorbitantly
high for contractors talk a little bit
about that maybe sure so you know
there's a lot of myths about mercenaries
there are modern mercenaries
coming back after a couple centuries of
being dormant and it changes the way war
is waged and I try to get at the truth
using fiction because that way I can
sort of tell the secret of world of
mercenaries without getting sued to
death which is my live my agent
initially said would happen to me
and the novel sorry I actually started
as a memoir and I turned it to fiction
and there's a lot of mess what is that
contractors make a lot of money they do
not they make you know like when I was
in this world I was making probably
double my army salary which is not a
whole lot and if you're from a country
donar are definitely a developing
country you kind of get lower rates even
for doing the same job which is unfair
you also get killed people die a lot in
the Iraq and Afghanistan wars towards
the end a lot more contractors are
getting killed and actual soldiers were
and the mortality rate is much higher
they go to where the fighting is there's
other myths - you know most a big myth
is that when the u.s. hires private
military contractors those contractors
are all former American veterans they
are not only a minority of them
Americans most of them come from all
over the world and they're fighting
American wars but they're not American
themselves there's all sorts of really
weirdness out there I recently
interviewed a trial attorney Mike
Papantonio who has been able to sort of
get around confidentiality and
non-disclosure agreements from his legal
work by fictionalizing them into he just
got the second of a series of novels it
sounds like you're sort of in a similar
situation right where when we look at
the Tom Locke novel series it is fiction
but generally speaking this is based on
your personal experience yeah
so the Tom walk novel series began as a
memoir of stuff I was doing in Africa as
a private military contractor someone's
a mercenary we changed it to fiction so
- obvious protection but those books
they kind of read there are
international thrillers they read like a
good breath or Dan Silva novel but there
as reality in the same way sort of like
john lecarre a the novelist pulled back
the curtain on what was really going on
the Cold War with this secret war of KGB
versus CIA and mi6 he was a former mi6
which is like the British CIA officer
waiting about that world as a novelist
I'm doing the same thing now as a former
private military contractor I'm
mercenary showing people what the what
modern warfare really looks like
googling oh who are these mercenaries
why are they fighting
what are they were they like and what do
they hope to achieve all that stuff
comes out and so the second book just
came out it's called deep black and this
takes with this takes place inside of
the Isis Caliphate based on actual
ground reports and sourcing there that I
have yeah John I could read one of my
favorite authors but I've read a couple
dozen of his books I would say just
about all of them really we've been
speaking with Sean McFate senior fellow
at the Atlantic Council of Washington DC
think-tank as he mentioned the latest
book is deep black a Tom Locke novel
Sean great to speak to you and I
appreciate you sharing your stories
today thank you very much it's a
pleasure to be on your show